some pressure by the Knights easily
broken by the Bulldogs when we at the
end / - as strong as that home I mean
that was all strength and athleticism
there the strike she's wrong and the tip
Oh senior with the block kiss birth or
three will reset feed you read a Clark
for the jab the fifty second chance
points and Judith you know with six
minutes to go enhances the reverse my
hat Sameera actually comes away with it
and now Tilly in transition Tilly to
akihabeera where the reverse layin
muscle by watching Mira and the foul
and you know what here's the thing about
barbecue that makes it even more special
not one [ __ ] could ever say a bad word
about that guy and he's young and this
guy could win he could get a thousand
wins he's in that kind of a drag right
now
parting Clark and final is on Hutchins
aura Jumeirah blows right past them and
puts him on a poster it is 10 inside six
minutes to go
it's agra trying to set up the sweet 16
rematch as Hachi burea moves the
Bulldogs closer to another date with
Florida State just gonna crush the way
trying to get out of traffic and
hatchery Moreau makes the mood 17-foot a
right down the hatch put up the shot
rebound Hampshire Matt very active
tonight coming off the six point game in
the round of 32 kiss / very good kiss /
first is a guy who's gonna take it to
the basket he's not a three-point
shooter you've got to keep him in front
see they're a double James on but got it
to go squeezing the trigger the twine
[Applause]
Willie until he began the season with a
beautiful feed from Julie on top they
got only I'll see now at the very top of
the defense on Perkins it's parked on
low Hechinger in chronic trauma buckets
the to how easy is that it playing for
the jump shot to Noah
how does that happen out of already
continuing to be matched up with Matthew
Murray was here a couple of years ago
spinning jump shot
how many pump makes was he gonna give
Kolber until he bit dad coached him here
today to watch him and a turnover is
some good consented events charge only
príncipe students tomorrow
Wiccans got the screen way to run this
office for a few requires 2 1 0 that's
really a good pass in a movement
tomorrow averages 20 ago chiseling his
way down oh we're talking about guys
better next level ready booty has just
been solid in this game 13 points
five attend look at the trials tomorrow
great defense there by hatch Amara
[Applause]
that gets the spins at 222 for hegemon
charts that didn't come it's a girl
loves it